i am delighted to welcome professor josh
tannenbaum who's computational cognitive
scientist
at mit in the brain and cognitive
sciences department here to yale um
josh is an amazing and brilliant thinker
and um you'll find that out if you don't
already know that many of us already
know that you'll find that out as we
have him here today to talk and i guess
what i'll
i mean
the thing i want to say about josh is
that he's
his his mind is amazing he's a wonderful
person he's a preeminent computational
cognitive scientist
um in i think
the world and
his genius was recognized in 2019 um by
the macarthur foundation um
for those of us that as i said uh
already know him we didn't need that to
recognize his genius but um
not much else i can say just that we're
very happy that you can
uh visit us today give the talk and
spend some time with us afterwards and
you are going to tell us about
what i can't remember
what
kind what kind of computation is
cognition yeah it's a question
deliberately so kind of computation is
cognition thank you all right
great thank you so much for having me
for lori and brian for inviting me um
it's it's a great honor and pleasure to
be here um
my understanding is this is one of the
first in-person seminars that people
have had here in a while it's also the
first in-person seminar that i've given
in quite a long time
so
maybe in my
in enthusiasm and excitement i tried to
pack in too much in this talk so i will
i will talk about some
thoughts on what kind of cognition
what kind of computation is cognition um
and a lot of this is really designed to
raise questions for discussion that then
i i hope we'll maybe have a few minutes
for with the larger group and also with
the class afterwards um okay so um
you know there's there's a few questions
in this talk um that is the main the
main one
but some questions in the background are
these ones um what would constitute a
meaningful answer to this question and
how do we know if it's right or even on
the right track
in the spirit of this seminar which is
an interdisciplinary meeting between
cognitive scientists and people
interested in metaphysics i wanted to
take this opportunity to raise these
questions which are essentially
questions of metaphysics and
epistemology about how do we model the
mind i think there are really
deep issues here to discuss
i'm going to present one approach i'm
not really going to talk about these
questions i'm going to present one
approach which i call the reverse
engineering approach and then i'd be
very interested to talk with you about
its pros and cons what makes sense what
doesn't and what are some other
approaches okay
i also think there's intriguing and deep
parallels between the way we think about
answering this question
and the way we think about actually
modeling the mind that reflects some of
the special relationships between
cognitive science
and
just more generally philosophy of
science and how we think about what
makes meaningful scientific questions
and models but that will just be in the
background and maybe we can discuss
afterwards
so
what i mean by reverse engineering is
trying to
characterize how the human mind works in
the same terms that we would use to
engineer an intelligent machine
okay um
but instead of doing artificial
intelligence we'll be doing let's call
it natural intelligence all right um but
our goal is to build models that look
like ai systems in a sense okay and
that is so that that's to me what a
meaningful answer to this question is i
would like to understand how the mind
works in those terms
and the way we know that we're on the
right track because i think none of
these models that we're going to talk
about are right but hopefully they're in
some ways on the right track is you know
the same thing we normally do in science
we compare our models to data that means
we try to capture qualitatively how
human behavior works we want our models
to behave like people but also
quantitatively the models often have a
lot of moving parts which i can only
begin to gesture at here for you
but in order to test those in some
rigorous way it often helps to have
quantitative data so i want to give you
a feel for how we do that
but
most distinctively i think our goal is
not just to capture the data from
laboratory experiments which are great
and the bread and butter are the gold
standard
but they're limited in in terms of the
scope of what we can do
our goal is also to build models that
actually solve the problems that people
do so we in my work and in a lot of the
work i'll talk about we do things that
basically look like ai they are ai in
some form we
implement our systems in robots or we
have them solve ai problems the same
kind of problems that humans face in the
real world and it's essential we think
to know we're on the right track that
the models both give a qualitative and
hopefully quantitative account of human
behavior but they also actually solve
the problem that humans have to solve
which gives us some reason to think that
they might be describing the actual
computations in the mind and maybe even
the brain okay but those are some of the
hard problems what does it really mean
to describe the actual computations in
the mind or the brain that i think we'll
only have time to discuss in the
following session
all right
now
to motivate this kind of approach i
think it's helpful to reflect on the
current state of artificial intelligence
or ai whether you are in cognitive
science or metaphysics or any number of
other fields including any of the
humanities you can't ignore ai it's
everywhere around us um for
for better and worse i think
and um but i i think it's also important
to reflect on on the state of what we
mean by ai um the way i like to put it
is to say we have all these ai
technologies increasingly useful and
perhaps
not perhaps actually increasingly
dangerous but increasingly powerful
technologies
um but we don't have any real ai okay at
this effectively what i mean by that is
we have these systems that do things we
used to think only humans could do and
now machines can do them to some extent
but we don't have anything like the
flexible general purpose kind of common
sense
the general notion of intelligence that
each and every one of you use to do
every one of these things for yourself
without having to be programmed by some
dedicated team of engineers at a big
tech company or a hot startup okay you
just do these things
and we don't have any machine that can
just do all these things for itself that
was the original vision of the founders
of the field right
what's sometimes called a general
artificial intelligence and it's the one
of the most interesting things about
cognitive science and study of human
cognition is how might the mind work
that we can do all these things and so
many other things for ourselves
now
reflecting on that gap i think helps to
motivate again
wha
what um what are possible ways to answer
the question of what kind of computation
is cognition and what i think are some
of the more promising ones i want to
just dive a little bit deeper into one
very useful
but but very imperfect ai technology
and that's self-driving cars as they're
sometimes called autonomous driving this
is an article which i believe is the
first
major press article on self-driving cars
particularly on the google effort which
is now something called wemo as part of
the alphabet uh corporate enterprise
i'm sure most people have uh are aware
of this there are now many many car
companies
working on uh and companies of various
sorts ai companies all sorts working on
trying to build cars that can drive
themselves and it's it's probably the
closest that um
we've come
uh to having actual robots with some
autonomous algorithms that don't have a
human in the loop except when they do
but effect
basically don't have a human in the loop
some of the time and they're out there
interacting with people in real world
settings that that really have major
consequences including life and death
consequences okay
um so
uh where are we in this enterprise well
this article was published in the new
york times in 2010
and just sort of announcing these first
efforts
that google was was working on
um it's now uh well eleven and a half
years later um by some estimates 100
billion dollars 100 billion dollars have
been invested in the enterprise of
building self-driving cars
and we're still not there this is a
recent article from just a few months
ago in 2021 about the costly pursuit of
self-driving cars going on and on and on
and all what's sometimes called the long
tail of problems all the cases that you
didn't really anticipate
that somebody didn't have data to learn
from in their machine learning system
that only come up as you make some
progress and then you realize nope
there's so much more and more and more
problems that we just haven't solved now
12 years later
wemo again which is the google or
alphabet company well by this recent
article in business week is 99 of the
way there but the last one percent is
the hardest
i don't think we're 99
i think they've been saying that for a
while um and i don't think they would
even say that um
the
weird echo thing for me
it's not just waymo but a number of
companies that have been promising
robo-toxies um
where are all the robot taxis were
promised well
uh
yeah they're not here yet it turns out
that um
we need some fundamental advances in ai
this is actually quite a good article in
terms of diagnosing i think what some of
the things that are missing and i'm not
going to go into it but it's going to
parallel what i'm talking about here or
another recent article from the wall
street journal self-driving cars could
even be decades away no matter what elon
musk says
because ai will have to get a lot
smarter so again i don't want to knock
this technology it's an amazing
achievement okay um that it works at all
um and in some sense it makes a lot of
sense that it doesn't fully work yet and
it's hard to even know when it will work
what's going on well the technology
there's lots of things that go on in
autonomous driving but there's a basic
thing that's been driving a lot of the
progress which also drives most of these
other progress
in ai technologies which is a certain
way to answer the question of what kind
of computation cognition might be and
you could say it's basically um oh and
um
oh sorry
turn my speaker off
there's no audi okay
there we go good yeah okay okay perfect
um
uh
it's a certain kind of machine learning
approach which you could call which is
often called deep learning and
end-to-end neural networks but if you
don't know what neural networks are i'm
sure probably most of you do know what
they are and i mean the artificial kind
of neural network that is uh an ai
technology these are these are
functional mappings functions that map
from inputs to outputs the inputs are
usually some kind of sense data like the
sensors of the car and the outputs are
behavior it might be conceptual behavior
like recognizing a pedestrian or another
car or making a decision okay and some
complex function that is implemented in
machine
in in the machine um has many many
parameters that can be trained they're
called neural networks because each
little bit of that
uh function what's called a unit in a
neural network of which there could be
millions or billions it's often hard to
keep track of how many there are in some
of these models
is sort of an abstraction of a neuron or
a nerve cell in the cortex
shown here from the famous early studies
of hubel and measle and early
mathematical abstractions what was
sometimes called the perceptron um going
back to the 90 early 1960s this work
that then over a series of decades
turned into increasingly bigger models
that represented bigger
more scalable attempts to basically
build these large trainable functional
mappings so for example in the work of
um
john le [ __ ] in the 1980s this is this
is a what was one of the early deep
convolutional neural networks that would
again take in for example a letter or a
digit and classify it
as a giving it a label a or three
a little more than ten years ago there
was a big breakthrough of progress where
people moment of progress where people
started applying these to
data sets of natural images and scenes
in computer vision like the famous
imagenet data set and this is the famous
alexnet architecture and you can see
that going from a single
um
nerve-like element that takes inputs and
weights and combines them in a
with a linear sum and then a threshold
as neurons do
to one layer multi-layer many many many
layered networks at this point these
systems get deployed in all sorts of
ways including inside for example this
is inside the tesla ai system not the
current state of the art but a couple of
generations ago but basically the same
kind of technology used to detect all
these things out there on the roads
this is a slide from some work of one of
my mit colleagues jim dicarlo and his
collaborator dan yeemans and others
where they've take these take take these
models which were um originally
abstracted from not just how nerves
neurons in the brain work but neurons in
visual cortex the part of the brain that
actually is the front end to object
recognition and then they've gone back
and many others have done this but their
their work is especially well known and
taken these the same kind of models that
have been used in computer vision and
shown that they can be used to make
predictions pretty good quantitative
predictions about the behaviors of
neurons in responses to images so it's a
compelling story in that these models
have been used for practical
applications and though you know this is
i'm not focusing here on like human
behavior but these models can to some
extent capture some aspects of human
behavior they can also capture the
behavior of neurons
and yet they're also missing a huge
amount okay and this is the gap that i
really want to focus on that motivates
the work that we're doing
well some part of intelligence is
probably about training functions to
approximate some classifier that can
recognize a pattern like a pedestrian in
an image
so much of intelligence goes beyond that
all these activities which why sort of
lump under modeling the world so not
just finding patterns in pixels but
being able to actually explain and
understand what we see
or to be able to imagine things that we
could see maybe things that nobody's
ever seen
and then think about what it would be
like if the world had those things in
them maybe set those as goals that we
could make plans to achieve and then
solve the problems that come up along
the way this is intelligence right
and then learning
is actually building these models so
that might mean adjusting or refining a
pre-existing model or constructing whole
new models maybe by combining pieces of
other models or actually maybe even
synthesizing a model
from scratch in some ways
it's all these activities that i think
many cognitive scientists are interested
in and in our work we're trying to
capture these
things in computational terms so the
question for for me here is what
computations can
or and in a formal way and in a
quantitatively testable way can express
these human capacities for modeling the
world and not just finding patterns and
data right now we're far from being able
to do these things at the scale that
silicon valley is uh ready to invest in
um
uh maybe that maybe maybe they would if
they knew more about what we were doing
but um
it's it's it's much earlier in the let's
call it the scaling curve all right um
what we've really been focused on in our
work over the last few years is kind of
the earliest most basic sense of how we
model the world which i like to call the
common sense core it's it's heavily
influenced by a program of research
that's sometimes referred to as core
knowledge in human cognitive development
liz spelke who is one of the leading
sort of developers of that whole
research program probably the world's
leading expert in that
she's going to be one of your speakers
actually the last speaker
so you'll see a lot of connection
between what i'm talking about today and
her work she's a friend and collaborator
also
and i think when i talk about the common
sense core here it's also deeply
connected to the basic
topics in metaphysics that i think the
class is studying it's this idea that
smelky and many others have developed in
developmental psychology as well as
people studying the human brain
and some amount of comparative work with
other non-human species
that from the very beginning in the
earliest in youngest infants that we can
study even say three-month-old babies
and in ways that are to some extent but
not completely probably shared with the
brains of other non-human species
we are built to understand the world not
just in terms of patterns and pixels
let's say but in terms of basic kinds of
concepts so we often talk about an
intuitive physics and an intuitive
psychology or objects actual physical
things in the world like this thing i'm
picking up which even if you've never
seen a cell phone or an iphone before
you know there's a thing i'm picking up
right and you know that if i were to let
go of it here that it would fall maybe
there would be a sound maybe there would
be something worse i'm not going to do
that but okay that's an example of an
understanding of physical objects and
some of the intuitive physics that
humans have from even at a very early
age we talk about intuitive psychology
and there we mean agents that could be
humans or could be other animals or
maybe a robot someday or a self-driving
car but an entity that has goals and
some model of the world itself and acts
in some way to achieve its goals
given its model
and the idea that we understand the
world in terms of physical objects and
goal-driven intentional agents and their
causal interactions is the heart of our
common sense and what i want to talk
about is how we can try to capture
that set of concepts that those
cognitive systems in computational terms
um
i'm not going to talk too much about the
brain side of this but there'll be maybe
a little bit depending on time or we can
we can talk about this so i'm mostly
going to be focusing on the cognitive
aspect but it's very interesting that
these systems also seem to be correspond
to some of the large-scale architecture
of the brain okay um and uh happy to
talk about that and and what the
metaphysics of that might be telling us
as well
the the work here is also i mean
for people who are familiar with the
different sort of subfields of cognitive
science one of the reasons why i like it
is it's really at the intersection of
the different traditional sub
disciplines perception language action
planning this is the basic stuff that
brings all those together the targets of
perception the substrate of action
planning
and the also the substrate of what we
talk about at least at the very
beginning when we're first learning
language right we we human adults have
the ability to do what i'm doing right
now and what you're doing which is
communicate talk and understand about
things that are not part of our basic
understanding of objects like this
and agents that pursue goals in the
world okay
we can talk about talking about that
talk about modeling that as well as
quantum mechanics and the origin of the
universe and the origin of life and
metaphysics and so many other topics but
in some sense this is where it starts
okay so to get a little bit more
concrete by intuitive physics
in young
children um i mean the kind of thing
that say this baby is doing here this
one and a half-year-old stacking up cups
or playing with their toys
now we have robots that can do things
like pick up objects and do simple kinds
of stacking operations but we don't have
any robot that can that can do what this
kit is doing including the physical
dexterity the ability to sort of solve
the little problems that come up along
the way when you're trying to achieve
your goal
a little bit of debugging going on here
but even just to to make the plan which
you can see that this kid is doing right
um even if you haven't seen this video
before you can see the stack of three
cups you can kind of guess where this is
going to go if i jump forward into the
video right to conceive of the goal to
make the plan
you know if we had robots that could do
this
it would be quite amazing all right um
by intuitive psychology i'll show one
very famous video from a very famous
study by felix wernicken and michael
tomasello this is also with a one and a
half year old but here the one and a
half year old is this little kid in the
back
who's a participant in the experiment so
he is watching an adult that's felix do
something that
he's never really seen before i mean
this is a this is a not crazy action but
it's a little bit unfamiliar if you
haven't seen this video now watch what
happens when the adult stops moving the
kid goes over
opens the door yep
yeah
so
you guys are totally with me because you
you you smiled and laughed and even awed
at all the best parts right um somehow
that kid is able to figure out what this
guy's doing for an action that is not
quite like anything he's seen before and
then even figure out how to help him
right and you can see that helping goes
on
when he goes over opens the door and in
some sense like the best part both
emotionally and i think scientifically
is when he steps back and looks up and
makes eye contact right at him and then
kind of looks down at his hands because
what you're seeing when you see that
right is at least a sign suggestive that
the kid has understood what the adult is
trying to do and is maybe almost even
signaling like i think i've understood
what you've done if so i think i know
what you're going to do which is now do
something with your hands okay
so again we don't have robots that can
do anything like that but imagine if we
did
they would be very helpful around the
house as well as other situations and
it's not my goal to build those robots
particularly although i work with
colleagues who do but the goal for me is
to try to understand in those kinds of
engineering terms what's going on inside
that kid's head now i'm going to show
one more video which i know some of you
have seen
it's one of the most famous videos in
cognitive science and i think it's it's
not unreasonable to call this the most
important two minutes in cognitive
science
um
brian might have other things like maybe
one of his experiments but
but it's a great um this is the famous
hyder and symbol um movie i'm not even
going to show all one and a half or two
minutes of it but just a brief excerpt
um but again
i'm sure many of you have seen this but
it really is like if you if you wanted
one
short video that makes the questions of
metaphysics and cognitive science as
what you know compelling as well as the
computational challenges this is this
would be it this is from a study in the
1940s in which people were just shown
this video of some shapes just moving
around on a tabletop
and yet what they see is much more than
just simple shapes moving in two
dimensions right
you see
what looks like an interaction between
agents one that is also sitting on top
of physics one that is maybe a little
bit
not super positive
right
at this point
um
maybe there would be some scary music
right now if this was a silent film
yeah
yes
what's gonna happen
all right so there's a little bit more
but we'll stop there yeah so it ends at
least some happily for for several of
the characters okay so what's going on
in here right i mean again um
you can
describe this in geometric terms but
what we actually see is all these other
things we see physical objects as well
as constraints like what is solid not
penetrable what's fixed what's movable
that when the door locks
you see it sort of gets suddenly
attached you see events and causal
interactions like collisions one thing
hits another and it moves but also it's
pushing and shoving and that gives you
an understanding in terms of like agents
might have goals towards each other
trying to hurt or help each other when
one's trying to escape or or trap
another one you see relationships like
you see those two as being kind of on
the same side they're friends or
something the other guy is kind of an
enemy
you experience or
you know maybe your own emotions but you
experience them experiencing emotions
right and probably make moral judgments
as well
so you know in a sense that this is the
the full challenge of trying to
understand common sense in computational
terms is could we build an algorithm
that could look at a video like this or
any movie of any groups of people
interacting
and make sense of it in all these terms
now again we're far from that but that's
that's the goal that's kind of what
we're aiming towards um and so what i'm
going to talk about today primarily are
how we can
represent these things computationally
and a little bit about how we study them
quantitatively and then you know at
least gesture at these questions of how
they might be instantiated in the brain
which maybe gives a different
perspective on what it might mean for
the the mind to really work this way if
it's circuitry in some sense implements
these computations um and then say a
little bit maybe about learning um both
how we learn let's say our intuitive
physics and also how learning can take
us beyond these things
so
the key computational ideas here and i'm
just going to try to be mindful of the
time and make sure that i get to at
least enough of the content so we can
have a reasonable discussion
and there's no clock so i'm going to
just keep referring to my
watch here but if i lose track of it
just you know let me know it's time to
stop basically okay um so the so
you know um
to answer the question what kind of
computation is cognition it's not just
neural networks for pattern recognition
and function approximation well here's
one proposal for some of the other
things we need um in our work we talk
about what's
we often use the phrase probabilistic
programs or probabilistic programming
which is one of kind of one of these
jargon terms like neural networks okay
it has something to do with
probabilities and programming just like
neural networks has something to do with
neurons but what it really refers to
is a whole sort of you call it a
computational paradigm there's math
there's programming languages there's
there's systems and platforms that i
know some of you are familiar with some
of you even use in your research but you
can think of it as ways of realizing in
in practical computational systems
a synthesis of several good ideas or
several paradigms or broad ways of
thinking about cognition and
computational terms one is the neural
network pattern recognition idea another
is what is the oldest and arguably most
important
way to think about intelligence in
computational terms which is the idea of
symbol manipulation or having symbolic
languages for abstract knowledge
representation and reasoning in the
early days of ai as well as in cognitive
science that's what everybody thought
about and as the these fields have had
their successes and their failures and
gone up and down
often
the so-called symbolic approach to ai
has gotten kind of a bad rap basically
people have said well early promises of
ai didn't work because everybody thought
we should be using symbols and then we
realized we had to use neural networks
but that is um let's call it fake news
okay that's the nice word for it um
because if you know if you had to
nominate one of these ideas to be the
most important one that's the most
important if we didn't have symbolic
languages we wouldn't have
you know natural language we wouldn't
have mathematics we wouldn't have all of
computing we wouldn't have programming
languages whether it's lisp or c or
python or modern programming languages
for deep learning like tensorflow or pi
torch we wouldn't have anything
basically
um
so that's that's that's an absolutely
central idea and we need ways of
thinking about common sense knowledge
that integrates learning and symbols
okay um and then a third idea which is
the one i guess my work has been most
associated with and is is is was one
that when i was in grad school and in
earlier times of my career was kind of
arguably the dominant idea
each of these ideas have had their
moments of in the in the sun as well as
in the shade but the idea of
probabilistic inference or bayesian
inference by which we mean often the
bayesian part of probabilistic inference
is kind of inverting conditional
probabilities specifically in a causal
setting where we have models of how some
things are caused by other things let's
say effects are caused by underlying
latent causes in the world we observe
the effects and want to work backwards
to make good guesses about the things
that cause them okay and that idea is
absolutely central we think in cognitive
science for understanding whether it's
perception or learning or how we make
sense of sparse
uncertain uh incomplete otherwise and
otherwise ambiguous patterns of data
which whether we're talking about
perception or language or learning it's
there's you're always in that setting
and probabilistic programs and the
discipline of probabilistic programming
and probabilistic programming languages
basically let us bring these ideas
together to
define
models of the of well to find scientific
models which are models of the models
inside your head for these common sense
intuitive physics or intuitive
psychology
using symbolic languages that support
causal models and then probabilistic or
bayesian inference so that we can in a
sense like run these programs backwards
to infer the underlying things in the
world
from the effects that we observe or the
effects that those things in in the
world cause on our on our senses right
and to use neural networks or other
machine learning tools to amplify and
extend what we can do with probabilistic
inference over these symbolic programs
if you want to learn more about this
approach beyond what i can talk about in
just high-level terms in this talk
i would encourage you to check out any
of these various probabilistic
programming languages or this web book
problmods.org which was written by noah
goodman and a number of other colleagues
noah is a professor at stanford
we've worked together for a long time i
co-wrote the first draft of this with
noah but it's gone through many
iterations since then a lot of other
people have contributed and noah has
been the one mostly carrying it forward
but it's a nice introduction
to probabilistic programming and
cognitive models based on probabilistic
programs
okay
there's another important idea another
kind of computational
tool
for capturing common sense
which is um
this this idea that i
described with the slogan the game
engine in your head
and this is the idea that tools from
game engines which again i think
probably many of you are familiar with
um some of you probably even program in
them
these are tools that were developed in
the video game industry
to allow somebody or a team to create
a new video game
much more easily than they would
otherwise in particular often to create
games that have some rich immersive
experience for a player in some you know
three-dimensional world maybe
it's um outer space or undersea or the
wild west or
uh dinosaurs or something that has never
existed except in the mind of the game
designers but could exist in some
possible world but to create a rich
immersive interactive experience
without having to write everything from
scratch so without having to like write
all of computer graphics but still make
the world look really good often nearly
photorealistic and to respond to what
the player does so as the player moves
around the world
or the images on the screen change in
the appropriate way so you feel like
you're moving through this world or as
you interact with the world it reacts
accordingly like so if i pick up an
object and drop it it has to fall if
it's glass or something fragile it might
break okay um so these these um game
engines often have like graphics engines
and physics engines as well as what
sometimes called ai engines or game ai
by which they mean tools for simulating
it's not really ai but it's tools for
simulating like the non-player
characters in the game so they react in
some vaguely intelligent way rather than
just a robotic way or like for example a
guard at a base might um instead of just
like shooting randomly into the air when
the player is trying to invade they
might like see you and go after you and
you have to like hide so they don't see
you for example okay um here's an
illustration of a game physics engine we
use these a lot in our work
um they in some sense just implement
physics right like whether it's
newtonian mechanics or other kinds of um
you know fluid mechanics
soft body cloth physics but they do it
in a way
that is designed not to actually be what
a physicist wants in a sense maybe
but to just look good
look good enough
to be very general to be able to model
all these different kinds of things
including simple systems of a few balls
bouncing around and much more complex
systems like hundreds or thousands of
blocks like in this wrecking ball case
and other very kind of complex non-rigid
or non-solid materials
and to be able to
look good on on look reasonable in what
they do going forward just you know on
the scale of maybe one or a couple of
seconds all right
and to be able to run in real time so it
can be interactive with a player or
maybe even faster than real time okay
now these tools have increasingly been
used in many areas of ai as a training
ground like for an ai algorithm so they
might be like
a typical thing that somebody might do
in a machine learning approach to ai
is to have a reinforcement learning
agent that like is that is deployed into
one of these simulators and then does
some things and learn some
some input output mapping some policy as
it's called a mapping from sense data to
behavior and then maybe you'll deploy it
in the real world and it has what's
called a sim to real problem it has to
figure out how to go from its training
ground in the simulator to act okay in
the real world that's a lot of what is
going on in self-driving cars is that is
the sim to real challenge and the fact
that like people are trying to create in
the simulator like every possible thing
that could happen in the real world and
that's not possible
um but the reason why we call this the
game engine in the head is because the
idea is that the game engine is a model
of what of the model inside the head
okay not the training grounds for a
learning algorithm but a model of the
mental models that when say a kid like
this one here sees this stack of blocks
and the toy bird on top and and has the
ball in his hand and imagines what would
happen if i roll the ball forward oh
maybe that would happen maybe it would
knock over the blocks maybe the bird
would fall
i'm not sure but imagining what might
happen then allows me to decide if
that's what i want to do or maybe it's
not what i want to do or maybe i should
do something differently and so on
so the the kind of models that we build
are we take these kinds of simulation
programs for say physics or analogous
ones effectively for agents
we wrap them inside frameworks for
probabilistic inference so that we can
for example sorry that the zoom here is
cutting off the bottom of the slides but
so for example we can build models like
what i'm sketching here
these are
these are sketches of the models we
build
not of the physical world but of the
model inside the kid's head for a
physical world or the model inside that
kid's head for what somebody's doing
okay so models that might take an image
or a sequence of images and make an
inference to what's the underlying state
of the world and its dynamics that would
that i could then predict forward future
what i might see at future times maybe
conditioned on my own physical actions
or this kind of thing here which is not
meant to be a picture of how your brain
works but how your brain thinks brains
work or what we sometimes call theory of
mind right it's one it's a standard sort
of picture of how of an intuitive model
of agents minds where agents have some
kind of goals or desires
they have some beliefs about the state
of the world and their state in it which
is a function of their perception system
they make plans to come up with actions
that are reasonable ways efficient ways
to achieve their desires given their
beliefs and then they
they exert actions on the world which
change the state of the world or change
their own state and and go on and so on
and so this is just a way that we're
used to often talking about how our
minds work that is the sort of standard
model and cognitive science of how even
a young child might understand somebody
else's actions and and what might go on
in a scene like that is observing
actions
given also your observations of the
world state and the agent state to try
to work backwards and fill in these
things to try to infer the underlying
mental states or beliefs and desires of
an agent in order to make sense of their
behavior
so our job here
is to take these sketches and turn them
into working
quantitatively testable computational
models so for example in intuitive
physics this is how we've done this and
this this this is work that in our lab
we started doing together with uh pete
battaglia and jess hamrick um and
they're the names on these slides and
there's a lot of other work people
especially um kevin smith tomer ullman
did key things in this research program
i'm just going to tell you about one or
two studies here
that go back to the earlier work of
battalia and hamrick um
uh
i should say also some some key work um
was done by one of our colleagues here
ilker yieldrim who used to be in our lab
and is now an assistant professor in
psychology and other fields here at yale
and
continues to do really exciting work
that relates to intuitive physics and
perception so if you're interested in
this topic ilker is one of the best
people in the world who does it and so i
highly recommend you check out some of
his work
um
so um but here here's here's like one of
the very first models we built like more
than 10 years ago at this point um the
idea is we're
we're giving people sorry i skipped over
this we give people these these like
scenes of these blocks they're they're
kind of um simulations based on the game
jenga if you're probably familiar with
that but they're colored in this way
and
these different stacks of blocks some of
them will look to you like they are
stable others will look like they should
be falling over
and we might have to make a judgment of
will it fall over or not or you can make
a graded judgment like on a scale of one
to seven can do it either fast or slow
it actually doesn't make that much
difference in our experiments um
actually in brian's lab with chas
firestone
they've shown they've done sort of
versions of this where you can people
respond extremely quickly you have to
get a brief presentation and you get
pretty similar results whether people
are making
very fast uh perceptual judgments or
slower
uh more considered judgments people are
pretty good at this problem of being
able to judge whether a stack of blocks
is going to fall over or as i'll show
you even to judge in a graded way how
unstable it is what does it mean to be
pretty good is actually something that
i'm going to be trying to be more
precise about but the way we capture
what's going on here is we say you
observe the image
and somehow you have to work backwards
to the underlying world state which is
the three-dimensional configuration of
these blocks their geometry and whatever
is enough about the physics like mass
friction the parameters the basic
parameters of physics that the physics
engine needs for its simulation okay and
we think of perception the basically
perception is the inverse arrow to this
one so given an image or a sequence of
images we want to work backwards this is
sometimes called inverse graphics to
figure out what was the input to the
the graphics program that is the thing
that would render the image from the
underlying world state okay
and i'm not going to focus in this talk
or really tell you at all how we do that
this is actually something that
appropriately trained neural networks
can be very good at learning this
inverse mapping you can also use other
kinds of approximate bayesian
computation more sort of top down like
guess in check monte carlo algorithms if
you're familiar with that
and
again ilker actually has explored a
number of those things in in his work
very interestingly
here we're just going to assume that
somehow given an image you get a
reasonable guess not perfect but a
reasonable guess of the positions of
these three-dimensional and
blocks in the world and sizes and shapes
and then that it's also the state of
this physics simulator where now you can
kind of run your simulation forward your
fast rough and ready approximation to
newtonian mechanics
run it forward a few time steps and see
what happens and if you take this
rendering here which is not exactly the
positions of the blocks shown here but
pretty close
and you run that forward well this is
what you get after a few time steps
that's think of that as one what's
called posterior predictive sample in
this probabilistic approximate
simulation based intuitive physics model
that's a lot of buzzwords but hopefully
you
you you've seen enough of what i've been
talking about to get some sense of what
those words are getting at all right um
here's another sample
um this is this is i'll just flash back
and forth between them
the difference is just the initial guess
of where the blocks are this is a a less
good guess if you look at this image
down here hopefully you'd agree this
isn't like a crazy guess compared to
lots of other positions of blocks but
it's a less good guess right
and you know we assume that our
perceptual system is just giving us some
some approximation to the true
three-dimensional scene structure
but whether you made this guess or this
guess when you run it forward in your
physics simulator basically the same
thing happens
um at the at the fine scale detail very
different things happen okay so the
final configuration of the blocks here
is quite different than the one here but
intuitive physics doesn't care about
that what intuitive physics cares about
is just most of the blocks fell okay so
that's the basis of this model you run a
couple of those simulations a relatively
small number like maybe five seven three
depend i mean we can try to measure this
quantitatively i'm not going to show you
how but like more than one but not very
many
and that yields
a fit to behavioral data that looks like
this here ignore the thing on the right
for now just look at the plot on the
left so what that scatter plot is
showing
is
it's plotting the vertical axis is
plotting the average human judgment on a
scale of one to seven where the high end
means it's we people think it's very
unstable those blocks are going to fall
all fall over the low one means very
stable not going to move okay
each plus represents one stimulus or one
block tower scene such as one of the
these are three shown here but in this
experiment there were 60. okay
the plus are error bars i think like 95
confidence intervals both for human
judgments and for the model so the model
is shown on the horizontal axis and it
that comes from running a small number
of the simulations like i showed you and
just computing the average or expected
number of locks that fell and what you
can see is it gives a pretty good fit
okay um
it cap this is when we say people are
doing are pretty good well that's what
we mean here is that they're pretty well
captured by this model
but there's another sense in which
they're not very good and that's what's
shown over here
this is in a sense the more correct
model this is the same physics simulator
but it doesn't have any uncertainty as
the first model does in where the blocks
are so this is like what you would get
if you could perfectly localize the
position of every block
all right
that's why there's no error bars in this
side right there's the vertical numbers
and error bars are the same that's the
human judgments but we've replotted the
data with a different x-axis
showing the actual number of blocks that
falls in each cases when you run that
simulation with the ground truth physics
and the ground truth correct object
position and it's a less good model of
people in the sense that the correlation
if you were to measure this is about
what we call a 0.9 correlation or
explains about 80 percent of the
variance the model explains that in the
human data this is more of a 0.6
correlation which is about 36 percent of
the variance right
so it's much less good model
um
and but but it also shows that in some
sense people aren't that good if you
judge by the actual correct answer that
you would want in your physics exam it
would be this one okay um
but what i would argue is that actually
this is the more useful one if you want
to build a robot that's actually going
to do this in the real world where
there's always going to be some
uncertainty in its perceptual system you
want it to be robust to uncertainty and
in a sense what you're seeing here is
that this model i would argue is just
not robust to uncertainty it in in a
sense
you could say people have um again i'm
sure you're probably familiar with
visual illusions and what they tell us
about perception
there's sort of this this model
um shows that people suffer from what
you could call a stability illusion
um you it sees people see stimuli like
this red dot which corresponds to this
red tower here which i'm sure most of
you think is unstable and should be
falling over but in fact it's actually
perfectly stable that's why the ground
truth model it it shows up as zero here
and there's many other things like this
many other stimuli to some extent like
this where in the ground truth physics
model they're either perfectly stable or
maybe just one block falls over but
people think they're much more unstable
so the judgments are much higher
what we show in this work right is that
that actually is captured pretty well by
this probabilistic physics simulation
it's just that the deterministic one
doesn't capture it so glass half full or
half empty you can say well this just
shows the limitations in our intuitive
physics the ways in which we're not that
accurate or you could say well this
shows the way that our system is
designed in its inherent computational
architecture to be robust to inevitable
uncertainties okay
so this is just sort of a little again
little mini microcosm of a much bigger
pattern of experimental things that
we've studied in our lab and many others
have studied at this point i'm not going
to go into much more detail but you know
we can ask many other questions like
of the same model which way will the
blocks fall how far will they fall what
happens if one color is much heavier
than the other notice how these two
towers here have the same geometry but
they get colored differently and you
make different predictions
by seeing these towers here that maybe
look like they should be falling but
they aren't you can make judgments about
how heavy or light some object might be
and we can do many other studies like
this um i'll show you um
since i'm just checking the time and i
don't want to run too much out of time
what i'll i'll
i'll show you just one other kind of
application of this which i think has
interesting connections to the
metaphysics side of things that i think
you've studied which is work from toby
gerstenberg and colleagues toby was a
postdoc in our lab for a number of years
he's now an assistant professor at
stanford in psychology
and he's looked systematically at how
people make judgments about causal
responsibility looking at
various kinds of events especially
dynamic events like these literally
looking at how people look at this what
you can see here is that blue dot you
might recognize is an eye tracker so
it's it's a trace of where somebody
looked as they were watching these
movies
and a typical kind of tobey experiment
is what's illustrated here where people
are asked in some kinds of trials to
make a prediction they see that this is
like a billiard ball scene i hope you
can see so this is a dynamic intuitive
physics setting and you might make a
prediction of what's going to happen
when a hits b will it go in the hole or
not oh yeah it just barely went in okay
in other trials
like what's here the question is not to
make a prediction
but to make it more of an explanation or
to say well in the scene did a cause b
to go in the hole right
so watch it and ask yourself that
question so did a cause b to go in the
hole
all right um well what toby found and
the reason why i'm showing this here is
you can see just in how people look at
these scenes depending on the question
that they're asking they look in a very
different way
look on the left here when they're
making a prediction okay
they kind of
they first look at see when these things
are going to collide and then they just
extrapolate forward where b is going
okay but when they're doing a causal
judgment so they're basically trying to
judge in a graded way how responsible
was a for making b going whole look at
where they're looking they're not just
looking at where b is going to go but
where b would have gone
if a hadn't been there do you see how
they're sort of trying to extrapolate
b's motion
and that's because there's a long
tradition of work some of which is
actually the core work that laurie
first became known for in metaphysics
which is looking at
how the role of counterfactual analysis
in in um
causal relations basically and i know
this is something i think you guys have
talked about in the class so i'm not
going to
try to retell in a limited way but it's
quite striking that you can see in how
people look at a scene that they're
doing this kind of counterfactual
analysis if and only if in very very
dramatic different uh
proportions they're making a causal
judgment um toby can also model this
using a probable with this probabilistic
physics simulation um and this is just a
sketch of how this works it's very much
like the block tower model that i showed
okay except that what the system is
trying to do is it's trying to make it
has to make guesses of what of the
counterfactual what would have happened
if a hadn't been in the scene you don't
actually know right um you can see those
eye movements in a sense those are the
guesses realized right there on the
screen in front of you they're not
perfect they're sort of noisy
extrapolations and the model though you
can't read it down here is basically
doing similar simulations with kind of
noisy estimates of the balls velocities
and positions
so the same idea of a noisy or
probabilistic approximate physics
simulation can be used to capture how
people predict what's going to happen
and the counter factual probabilities
they have to compute in order to make a
causal responsibility judgment
and i won't go into the details of how
you study this experimentally but toby
is has has done really wonderful
experiments where he manipulates the
degree of how close or far the
counterfactual is and how that separates
from the actual one and gets very
beautiful fits to data so just it's an
advertisement for basically really
elegant work that shows the quantitative
power of these models for capturing a
sense of causality and causal
responsibility and not just predicting
what's going to happen next okay
um one more advertisement and i'll try
to keep this even shorter but this is
recent work from kelsey allen and kevin
smith who i mentioned where they're
adding in that the next step which is
how do you use probabilistic intuitive
physics to solve problems okay in this
case thinking about the human ability to
make and use tools in novel creative
ways right again when we think about
cognition we think about creative
problem solving as a as a as a core
aspect of where our general purpose
intelligence comes in
many people who studied the evolution of
human intelligence focus on the human
ability to not just make tools but to
just sort of find and repurpose things
like this stick or this rock or think of
all the things i could use this phone
for that aren't just making a call right
your phone's battery is dead is it
useless well depends right i'm gonna
unstick this or
um you know you have to uh well i won't
go into it okay but
in this in this paper which was which
was published uh back in 2020 feels like
just yesterday like a lot of things in
2020. um
uh in um
pnas
they show they had people playing this
really cool virtual tools game where
they basically have to solve these
problems the problem is always get the
red ball into the green goal
and there's there's many different
things that happen in this in this in
these different levels of this game it's
kind of inspired speaking of phones by
these like touch physics phone games
which are popular pastime
and um what they show is that basically
a probabilistic simulation based model
provides a good account of of the
internal process we we posit of people
sort of trying out ways they could solve
the problem by picking a tool and
thinking about where they might place it
into the scene
it can capture both where people choose
when they
to drop objects um as well as a sort of
the learning dynamics and this and what
this graph is just showing
is
is there's sort of this rapid trial and
error kind of learning here
sometimes you might see people talk
about reinforcement learning algorithms
and in ai and say well they learn like
people or animals by trial and error but
but unlike what's called reinforcement
learning typically in ai people don't
learn from you know thousands or
millions of training examples they do do
trial and error learning as we all often
do when we're trying to solve problems
but the real trial and error learning is
something that unfolds over like five or
ten trials and that's what we see in
this virtual tools game as well as in
the model
okay
um
so i guess i don't have time to talk
about intuitive psychology
um
but um what what what i'll just um
uh
uh i'll i i do want to advertise two
things one is um if you're interested in
how these kinds of ideas play out in
understanding intuitive psychology um
you're again very lucky here at yale to
have one of the world's experts in
julian hara edinger and his research
group
they do many things but but among other
things they have developed models for
and and sort of taken the kind of models
that i've described here and and shown
all sorts of really cool things to do
with them and i'm not going to go into
the details of those um but but i but i
do want to show you the following work
um and again i guess we could just call
it mostly an advertisement but since i
bothered to show you hydro and symbol um
i want to emphasize the work that is
completely hidden on the bottom because
of the zoom thing i'm going to just move
that for this purpose here
um
it's been a
it's been a dream of many cognitive
scientists and certainly of mine
to be able to
to be able to really study take that
hydra and symbol video and basically
build models that can really see
everything that people can do there now
we we aren't there yet okay but maybe
we're like 99 of the way no not even
close but maybe we're like
40 percent of the way um
so this is really exciting work by aviv
netanyahu and chiang minshu that they're
the kofirs authors which they published
a version of it at a recent ai
conference but it's honestly it's even
more exciting as cognitive science than
ai um it's this phase paper
and what they've done is they basically
built this little domain
that they call flatland where you can
see these agents here that are basically
interacting with physical objects they
can like pick up things exert forces
throw them
and it allows us to capture in a
controlled quantitatively studyable way
many of the things that are going on not
just when you see a single agent like
try to pursue a goal but when you have
multiple agents interacting like in the
hider and symbol video
so in this setup agents some agents are
strong some are weaker
agents can have different goals like an
agent could say
the red thing here could be to get to
the gold thing or the agent could just
have a goal to get to another entity
the agent here could have a goal to get
the blue ball to the red space these are
possible goals that the agents could
have
they also have relationships and social
goals so agents could be helpful to each
other as you can see here where it looks
like the red agent is trying to help the
green agent get the blue balls to
somewhere they could be adversarial like
the way they seem to be fighting over
where this ball is to go or they could
just be independent like the green one
wants to get that ball up to the greek
up to the green space and the red one
just wants to go down there so these are
all possibilities the cool thing is
these weren't made by humans these were
made by our model so we have a model
which is a a probabilistic generative
model of these multi-agent interactions
it sits on top of a physics engine
because you can see that these agents
are interacting with physics and each
agent has its own sort of goal and
representation of its social
relationship and the other agent's goal
and then they do some fairly complex
planning process to generate the
sequence of behavior so the the
probabilistic program
goes from these underlying physics and
social variables and produces the movies
but then you can run it in reverse it's
not easy but with the right kinds of
inference algorithms you can then also
see the movie and work backwards to
infer what those goals are
both the individual ones the social ones
and then also run it again forward and
predict what's going to happen next
and so you can see in this
in this world with this generative model
it can produce quite interesting
behavior so for example here you have
here you have an
agent that's um well notice what happens
here you can just see what happens the
green one goes and steals the blue one
and then the red one goes and fights him
for it okay um
uh
and and successfully gets it back okay
so there it's an adversarial interaction
but because
the
because the red one didn't see the green
one initially he kind of left the blue
one unprotected okay notice this scene
the only difference is that the red one
now can see the green one so
he doesn't go and leave it unprotected
he stays there to protect it that's the
only difference is the partial
perceptual observability that this
system gets
or you can try this it's a little sort
of turing test here so
on the top you see two adversarial
interactions let me move this again um
one is
one is
generated by
the machine
another is actually generated by two
people playing the game
can you tell which one
is the human and which is the machine
um i'll give you let me give you another
thing here so on the bottom this is now
a helpful interaction where the green
one is trying to help the red one or
sorry the red yeah they're trying to co
collaborate to get the blue ball into
the yellow square
so raise your hand if you think the ones
on the left
are the human
raise your hand if you the ones on the
right are the humans
okay most of so so um well most of you
were right um
uh i should have asked you how confident
you were so in our
in our actual experiment when when um
well yeah now you know the answer um so
when we have people judge these one at a
time
um people are almost about equally
confident that they are sort of natural
human things when you put them side by
side you can see some subtle cues which
you're clearly all seeing and i'm happy
to discuss that afterwards what some of
those cues might be
but
but hopefully i think what you'll agree
is that these are fairly natural kinds
of interactions that really capture the
ways agents might collaborate or compete
okay
um
let me go back to the zoom thing so um
uh okay so there were a couple of things
that i didn't get to talk about but i
will just
remind you that i didn't talk about
these things um which is how does this
work in the brain
and how might these things be learned
i'll just say the one sentence answer is
there are particular regions the
particular parts of the brain actually
which we can show with functional
magnetic resonance imaging given the
same kinds of stimuli that do respond to
these sorts of things and when it comes
to learning
um we can we can actually start to build
models of how people learn these sorts
of things laurie is going to drag me off
the stage
that's fine um
and um
the the the thing the the one sentence
thing i want to leave you with on
learning is just the following idea
which is if we want to build learning
algorithms that can learn
um like a simulation program
the learning algorithms in a sense have
to be what we call program learning
programs okay so
what kind of algorithm could take as
input experience and produces output
another program which is itself like a
probabilistic approximate simulator
let's say a physics okay
this is a this is an interesting
challenge okay it's not the sort of
thing that you have when you're trying
to learn a neural network
we sometimes call this to contrast with
learning in a neural network where
there's a smooth error surface and you
can use these gradient descent
algorithms basically just
multi-variable calculus to optimize all
the parameters to train the system to
produce the right input output behavior
if your goal is to search through the
space of all simulation programs there's
no nice topology or geometry it's a much
harder search problem but somehow you
know people are able to solve this and
we want to understand how
i what i will just say is like this is
just sort of call this the future of the
study of i think human learning and
computational terms and
more human-like machine learning
and the advertisement here is for a
recent um opinion piece in trends and
cognitive science by josh ruhl another
former recent student and recent
graduate along with steve pandosi where
we we introduced this metaphor perhaps
an ill chosen name but the child is
hacker you might have heard of the child
of scientists the idea that children's
learning is like a kind of scientific
hypothesis testing and experimentation
by hacker here we mean like not the bad
guys who break into your email and steal
your credit card numbers but the mit
notion of hacking and i think maybe they
have some of this at yale too
like
creative exploration whether it's a
world of code or worlds of you know
tunnels or whatever it is but basically
all the ways in which we think we can
basically think of constructing
knowledge the way we construct like a
body of code so it's not just taking an
existing program with a bunch of
parameters and tuning the parameters but
it's actually algorithms that write code
and there's all sorts of like sort of
bubbling ideas bubbling little examples
of this in the kind of cognitive ai
literature at this point and i'll just
say check out this paper to see some to
see a review of some of those and how
those might apply to thinking about what
i what i'd say is the future of human
learning which is really algorithms that
write algorithms okay whether it's a
physics engine or all the other things
that we learn
okay so that's it
this is the actual last slide
okay
um
i hope uh you've gotten at least a taste
of how we can use these tools to capture
some of the aspects of common sense
but i also think the hardest questions
remain so now i'm happy to have you
throw them out of them very good by the
way josh you said one sentence and i
counted it was 22 sentences okay um
that's just what i deserve we have a
dangerously small time for questions now
because josh has a seminar to get to
soon but we will take at least several
minutes for questions since we have a
lot of students here in the audience i
think the first question for you josh
has to be
what kind of formative educational
experience like what kind of college did
you go to that could have led to such a
brilliant ambitious research program oh
well
what a great question i think it might
have been ezra stiles college
or as we used to yeah it kind of looks
like this but different
sort of yeah so yes no i was a yale yale
college undergrad before there was this
great cognitive science program
um which is
in large part due to some of the efforts
of brian and a number of colleagues here
at this point um so
fantastic so let's open the floor up uh
open the floor up for questions here
very good
yes thank you
oh do you want
thank you a lot for your okay uh thank
you for a lot for your talk so um
i've been so i i'm new to this so this
might be naive so i i heard about
probabilistic coding and i know about
the neural network
so
can you build them like a framework like
what we are currently doing in chip we
want designing chip we have a very large
software where we can like uh use for
example probabilist coding to design to
design the architecture and to convert
to our neural network implementation
so
do you think that uh framework is
possible to build and if yes
um
like
we're actually so i if i understand you
correctly
i think what you're asking is
can you
implement these ideas which i described
you know let's say at the software level
right i talked about programs and
algorithms can you implement them at the
hardware level could you imagine a chip
let's say that like implements these
computations in some physical device
much as we we have chips that that do
something similar for for neural
networks
some of those are specially designed
chips others are ways that people have
figured out how to use the the graphics
gpus or graphics processing units which
are effectively
chips for that were designed originally
for computer graphics which can be
repurposed for training and running
neural networks and what i hear you
asking is is there a similar way to to
design like physical circuits that
implement these computations is that
what you're asking
yeah basically because because um
probabilistic coding is fantastic for
human understanding one net neural
network is currently what we are
implementing in our brain so i'm trying
to figure out so how does this fit with
neural networks in the brain basically
yeah okay that so that's that's an even
i mean the first question was a good
question this is a related but even
better question i think and it's one
that there's no way i can really do it
justice here um but for those who are in
the class i hope we can we can discuss
it some more
um
i think so again what i think is lurking
behind what you're saying and i even
reinforced this in the beginning of my
talk
is that
we we have
like we have these things which we call
neural networks which that term actually
means two different things there's the
the original neural network which is the
brain right if anything in the world is
a neural network it's the brain because
it's right okay but then there's these
things called artificial neural networks
which are the the the tools that people
in machine learning use right
now they're related to each other in
that the artificial neural networks
their basic units their basic primitives
are in some
way inspired by what we understand about
how actual neurons in the brain work
but that inspiration is loose and
limited right like in the very early
days of neural networks in machine
systems
that was a tight link relatively i mean
we just didn't know very much we didn't
have very much on computer
technology
and we knew less about how neurons in
the brain work
at this point what's called neural
networks in machine learning artificial
neural networks is goes quite beyond
anything that we actually understand
about the brain or maybe is also quite
less like much less i mean basically
there's almost no relation
at this point there's a there's there's
there's a basic core relation but it's
not right i think to take today's
artificial neural networks and say that
that's how real biological neural
networks work like there is some
relation
but it we can't assume that
like if the way to relate the software
models of probabilistic programming that
i'm talking about here the way to relate
that to the brain is to go via an
implementation in today's artificial
neural networks that's one possibility
and we and others have worked on that
actually i i've referred several times
to ilker yieldrum's work he has some
really nice work um
in his group looking at that kind of
thing okay um mario belladonna who's
here somewhere uh there's mario mario's
worked on that also with elker and a
number of others okay so that is one
thing you can do you can try to
effectively compile these probabilistic
programming things into an artificial
neural network and say maybe that's how
the brain works i'm not saying that's
wrong i'm just saying we can't assume
that is right another thing you could
try to do and other people have been
working on this
is to try to say well maybe there's some
mapping between the probabilistic
computations that go on under the hood
to give you the numbers which i showed
you here
and the the probabilistic spiking
behavior of neurons that sort of when
you you could have networks of
stochastic spiking neurons which if
you've studied neural circuit modeling
that's actually often the way
computational neuroscientists describe
real biological neural networks and it's
possible that those kinds of
implementations could in a more direct
way implement some of the probabilistic
inferences that we do to produce the
pictures i showed you here
basically monte carlo the monte carlo
principle that says you approximate
probabilities with
sums empirical expectations over
stochastic simulations that's that's
what's behind a lot of what i showed you
and that can be implemented directly in
networks of spiking stochastic spiking
neurons so that's another route to try
to make this mappings they're both like
much to be done in the future to really
see if any of those are going to work
but that's that's i think especially
exciting to try to relate these models
of the mind to models of the brain and i
think that's also going to be central to
really having a fully satisfying answer
to what kind of computation is cognition
that was a very satisfying answer not
all of the answers can be that long okay
um let's take some more questions and
since that was a computational
sort of oriented question i believe one
of the people who had their hands up
still in the back uh let's move to a
philosophy-oriented question uh with a
uh
we're not supposed to say our names
because of releases but this person's
name may or may not be michael
fortunately we're we're we can do
probabilistic inference
thank you brian and thank you josh uh i
just a couple of times in the talk you
mentioned
you you poo poo the idea that we're 99
of the way there we're more like 40 of
the way there
what what would 100 of the way there be
like and would would being 100
get a success of any kind um
so i'm trying to investigate what would
success look like right so that i did
encourage you to ask that question so
thank you for asking that
difficult question um i i i think it
depends well wait can can you let him
keep the mic for one second do you mean
success towards so i use those numbers
like 99 in both both
um somebody's estimate of how close are
we to an ai goal like self-driving cars
or also how close are we towards some
kind of cognitive modeling goal which
one were you asking well i was thinking
like the success like if you have
something that can behave just like
humans do and could they pass a train
test for example yes and
what what why would that be success if
this touring test can be passed that's
interesting but what does it tell us
about the human mind
yeah
so
i don't know if i can answer that
without in in a short answer and brian
has no but
but a haiku
okay this may be more like 22 syllables
than
12. but um
this is about scientific model building
right um
and i don't think i'm going to be able
to give you a fully i don't think i
don't i don't know that i can give you a
fully satisfying answer to that question
at all let alone the one you want me to
answer right here okay
but
i think as in most other areas of
science you know how do we know when our
models are on the right track
well it you could call it some notion of
coherence and i think this is like basic
metaphysics and epistemology which my
philosophy colleagues can tell me more
about
but when you have a model that captures
many different
ways of getting at the same phenomena
all right that can include different
kinds of behavioral judgments that we
can study in the lab that can include
acting like a person in the
corresponding real world scenarios
that's the sort of ai tests of the model
and as we're starting to be able to do
that can also maybe even predict some
neural responses okay which i didn't
show you that these models are able to
do but they're starting to go in that
direction okay if this if the same class
of models can explain or let's say can
just fit all those different sorts of
data and i would say even explain them
in the sense that gives a functional
explanation of why the behavior is the
way it is why the neurons are the way
they are because we would argue this
compute this computational approach is
actually solving the real world problems
in some efficient effective way
i think that's that's a
a coherent kind of
at least epistemology here and maybe
even metaphysics um i think
fundamentally right what what is lurking
behind this approach and i can try to
unpack this in less haiku-like fashion
later on
is
that
i think at least and i think most most
of us as scientists think the world is
real it is really real thing
but the best we can do in our science is
to build models of it and that's true
when we're doing science and it's true
when we're doing cognition also right
this view of the mind that i'm talking
about here and that is i think a
canonical one in cognitive science is
this idea of the mind as modeler and
model builder
and i think the same kinds of tools of
probabilistic modeling prediction
including counterfactual or hypothetical
data like the same things that we think
the mind does we as scientists do
it's just the data isn't the data coming
into our retinas it's the data that we
get when people press buttons and say
things when we put things through their
written right and i think that basic
notion of coherence and modeling
is at the heart of why you know part of
how we as as humans intuitively
understand the world it's what makes
satisfying understanding in
in pretty much every area of science
that i know
and i would love to explore more
trying to make that more rigorous
argument i think let's just say
let's take one more question before josh
is shuttled up
to
the seminar that he'll talk to
and someone whose name may or may not be
jack
hi i have a question about um sort of
the architecture here when you
introduced the
game engine
part of cognition part of learning
are you
is the claim there that that's sort of a
separate self-sufficient module and if
if so how does it
interface with symbolic or semantic
representations
right okay um
uh because time is short i there's a lot
to unpack there for people who maybe
don't know everything you were talking
about but i will just say
so
um
these models
uh so so okay so so there's a
there's i guess a standard cognitive
science view that i think maybe you're
referring to like a sort of voter
modularity of mind language of thought
kind of set of questions right um
so to translate this
picture into those terms i would say
there's not the single module in the
mind or brain that's the game engine
there's actually a set of brain systems
that i can even tell you where they are
based on some of my colleagues fmri work
that are both you know somewhat
functionally distinct subsystems they
also interact in ways and like actually
a good chunk of the brain
can be
mapped onto these different parts of the
game engine in this model um ilker wrote
a nice review of this in current opinion
in neurobiology a couple of years ago on
at least the sort of object physics part
of that so i refer you to that paper for
one part of it but i think with with
some other colleagues who've been
studying like basically social cognition
networks whether it's theory of mind or
other ones so you can actually look at
the brain and see some both modular
structure but also interacting models so
it's not like it's they're they i would
say they have some interesting
informational interfaces they're they're
not as encapsulated as foder would have
said but there is some functionally
distinct substructure okay
but
you also asked about like traditional
symbolic and semantic knowledge so i
think a really important part of this
research program
is that these models are what i think
many cognitive scientists might call
like
pre-semantic they're often more like
perception i mean brian and i will argue
about this probably in a few minutes um
and i think no it's really interesting
and um
that in many ways these models are more
like perception than
uh like cognition even if brian might
say sometimes he might i mean i i'll let
you say but like they have some
components of the way brian who draws a
strong line between perception and
cognition would call perception and
others that are more like cognition but
they are certainly not like um you know
sort of uh traditional linguistic
semantic
verbally expressible knowledge i think a
lot of our early word meanings
and some of our early syntax is actually
sits on top of this like early syntax
and semantics
and syntax semantics mappings and like
verb lexical semantics sits on top of
this kind of basic stuff and i mean i'm
just channeling things that like ray
jackendoff or tommy and many others
would say okay but
or lila gleitmann for example um but um
uh
the key thing here is that
sim symbols
should not be restricted to language
like
semantic knowledge it's essential that
these models as we build them are
symbolic okay now they're also they also
have to be neural that's going back to
the first question
but by far at this point by far our best
models of these kind of game engine
things are symbolic representations that
have object structure compositionality
all the usual nice
like voter pollution things these have
them in spades okay they also support
probabilistic inference and they can
also support learning so if one is used
to thinking you know oh well symbolic
languages that that's somehow distinct
from
uh like a statistical inference or
probabilistic inference module and then
somehow learning comes into this like if
there's one note to maybe just take home
from this and end on it's that i think
to really understand cognition we have
to go beyond those that way of kind of
parceling out responsibility in terms of
different computational motifs and say
no actually to understand common sense
these all have to come together you have
to be able to have fundamentally
symbolic representations of the
structure of the world but that support
probabilistic inference and that also
support learning and i think you know
we're starting to see some steps it's
not 99 and it's not even 40 but it's
significant steps towards seeing how
that synthesis might play out
with apologies for the rush schedule let
us thank professor joshua
[Applause]
just